Indonesia is an incredible country with
17,000 Islands 800 languages and
dialects and more than 300 ethnic groups
after centuries of oppression it is
looking for a common future and a
national identity
the idea of a single national language
only came to the fore in the 1920s and
with it emerged modern Indonesian
literature Linda Christine he writes
about the traumas of the past
okay Bruce meanie explores the tensions
within society
oh sorry are you rights of things that
can't be said writing as therapy as a
weapon
indonesia lies between the Indian and
Pacific Oceans the capital Jakarta is on
the island of Java
30 million people live in and around
jakarta the city is booming the country
is rich in natural resources but for a
long time its riches were exploited by
colonial powers Indonesia only gained
independence from the netherlands after
the Second World War
when I was a child I was so happy
because i live in Indonesia and this
country is very rich and this country
has a lot of languages we have a lot
cultural and we have a lot at Nick's
here and of course at the same time I
worry when I'm thinking about how the
government can minute this country how
the government can bring prosperity to
the people how the government can bring
justice to the people or everything
because too big and big country has a
lot of happy stories and a lot of sad
stories too
the writer and journalist Linda Crist
aunty is all too familiar with
Indonesia's sad stories every Thursday
she comes here to the presidential
palace to attend a demonstration of
political activists and critics of the
former suharto regime may read a poem
about the people who were seized and
disappeared about our friends who were
kidnapped it's a poem I wrote myself
Julie we sequence and Yuri words against
silence linda wants to know what
happened to friends and comrades who
were abducted during the military
dictatorship the demonstrators chant we
will not be silenced they call on the
president Joko Widodo to bring the
perpetrators to justice so to hurry ki
tamanna dorito la jolla disco fendi arab
azaria no coupon you pick iran t gusta
ko's denon rocco's ockendon grow go piss
a fellow taxi Appa pune and ricky air
con tanta bebes a pen yara in liberal a
key swap is been to kiya mera pehla
buren chameleon purse isa bloom stop
Aluna bebehs a pitcher Rita Tintin
kalyan yang pergi dan tidak akan valley
a conveyor cerita inclusive our East an
agar a peony rose meow
the flame of freedom in stone the huge
national monument in the heart of the
capital commemorates the struggle for
independence after three and a half
centuries of foreign rule its
construction started in 1961 under the
direction of the Republic's first
president sukarno he sought to unite the
nation through nationalism and communism
in 1965 there was a coup eventually
Suharto seized power and remained
president from 1967 until May 1998 he
was ruthless in crushing opponents
in the late 1990s Linda helped organized
the student protests that ultimately led
to the ousting of Suharto she went
underground and wrote anti-regime
articles under a pseudonym I don't know
what happened to us because we are very
young at the time is all of us were 20s
and we decided to sacrifice our life to
the people and we know we know about the
risks maybe the government will arrest
us maybe they will send us to the jail
maybe they will kill us maybe they will
make us disappear maybe they will send
the military intelligence kidnap Us and
all of us we know about it we know about
it at that time but we took the risk
because if nobody dares to do that the
country are the people's were still the
same no futures for the young generation
under the dictatorship leftist writers
were banned though their works are now
available the band was never officially
lifted a conspiracy of silence prevails
to this day in Indonesia despite the
restoration of democracy nobody dares to
bring the culprits to justice it is
because of military they were involved
in all of violence cases in indonesia
indonesia was built on maybe more than
one millions that people yes and and i
think it's almost impossible to military
military to say all we will tell you the
truth we kidnap your son we can name
your daughter maybe we can have your
husband and now we want to say forgive
us it's impossible
it's will never never heaven in her
prize-winning literary texts essays and
reports Linda writes about violence and
terror from Sumatra to Timor
indonesia suffers from enduring tensions
between the interests of the central
government based in the capital on Java
and those of the other islands there is
little that keeps the regions and
islands together an official national
language bahasa indonesia was only
introduced in 1945 after the declaration
of independence i had multiple multi
identity i was born in both ireland
people call me buncombe is maybe because
i live in this country people call me
indonesian they call me muslim
indonesian muslim and when i attend a
brighter conference they call me
indonesian writer identities it's not
something like wood or stones it's like
liquid yes
the majority of Indonesians are Muslim
Indonesia has the largest Muslim
population of any country and it boasts
the largest mosque in Southeast Asia the
east ich lull or independence mosque in
Jakarta with room for 120,000
worshippers
Linda considers herself a critical
Muslim she's worried that the
traditionally moderate Islam of
Indonesia could be subverted by more
extreme currents she was brought up to
respect others whatever their beliefs
little by little I realize you cannot
understand religion if you only read oh
go on because you have to know more
about politics and you have to know more
about the conflicts between people and
why they fight each others in the name
of God
it was Arab traders who brought islam to
the region until then Hinduism had
prevailed Western colonialists brought
Christianity but it did not really catch
on
many ethnic Chinese here practice
Buddhism or Taoism these days less than
2% of the population call themselves
Hindus in the northwest corner of the
country on the island of Sumatra about
1,800 kilometers from the capital is the
semi autonomous province of a che
there are almost no traces now of the
tsunami that devastated the west coast
of archie on december 26 2004
amazingly this mosque remained standing
the tsunami killed 170,000 people in
Aceh province alone for the writer azari
ayub the disaster changed everything i
was born in Banda Aceh I spent my dear
hood here before tsunami I live with my
family I have one little sister and one
little brother with the tsunami all of
them disappear it is still hard for him
to talk about it especially here at the
beach where people relax and swim just
as they did before the huge wave struck
his sadness finds expression in verse
but he does not like to read his poems
out loud himself
I beaucoup abba dan Vic no mo satella
valla aku pulang ningun militia carry on
dan Campo
to Kira gumnaam December joonam in pboro
tapi aku bukan Korea and I sana juga
Erica till young Tarawa
so practically our camp on kita Raghava
sudachi odda rubra mens are allowed
Uriah
he and his family lived just a couple of
kilometers from the shore vegetation has
filled the plot where his home once
stood
the entire village was washed away
before tsunami we have 700 people but
after we remind 100 people ate
organizations from a hundred countries
came to Archie a region that had been
cut off from the outside world for
decades because of the war between
separatist insurgents and the military
after tsunami many projects by contrast
in a check and build many hosts in the
tsunami area
half a million people were made homeless
here most now have a roof over their
heads but in their hearts they're still
suffering I look like I am stranger here
because so many newcomer after tsunami
in my police the village where asari
grew up has been rebuilt new houses and
new residents garea for sorry the place
is still full of memories the first
books his father gave him the first
stories he was told as a small child my
mother is like a story like like a
storyteller sometime in night or in the
afternoon she telling everything what
she know sometime about the fairytale
sometime about the gossip and when I'm
writing something I stolen the story by
my my mother
Azari now lives on the outskirts of the
regional capital Banda at shave
when it's tsunami hit he was far away on
Java it was days before he heard that
his family had been killed the pictures
on the walls of his home are all of his
wife's family he doesn't have a single
photo of his own parents sister or
brother he says he's frightened he might
forget what they looked like
after the tsunami tens of thousands of
people were buried in mass graves many
had not been identified there's now a
tsunami Museum in Banda Aceh
the names of 5,000 of those who perished
are inscribed here
there are dioramas of the event itself
and of the aftermath to help visitors
understand what happened
right beside the museum is a Dutch
military cemetery where more than 2,000
soldiers of the colonial power are
buried the Netherlands and the Sultanate
of aceh were at war for three decades
until akshay capitulated in 1903 I
jenny's define themselves as the fighter
that historic conscious is very high we
are surrounded by the history we talk
about about previous time and we don't
care about what happened in the future
Archie is one of the poorest regions in
Indonesia the war that began in the
1970s between a separatist insurgency
and government forces crippled the
economy for decades many people of
Azura's age grew up without their
fathers they were away fighting in the
underground many were captured tortured
and murdered violence was everywhere
even in the most remote villages and it
is very present in Azura's short stories
this is the arch a human rights museum
it's based on what used to be a private
home ah sorry is the director the
founder Raisa yttria who's studying at
Harvard is back for a visit where have
you been oh you've gained weight yes but
it's not from bribe money after the
tsunami as re shared this house with
other artists and writers who had lost
their families their small community
developed into an art center and a Human
Rights Museum the tsunami prompted
renewed efforts to resolve the conflict
in Aceh a peace deal was signed in 2005
to ensure the conflict is not forgotten
the museum collects documents on
killings massacres arson attacks abuses
the old and the new rulers do not want
to address anger and resentment towards
the government remain deep
we know about Indonesia only one phase
phase injustice face abuse of Human
Rights and face lapping of our woman so
we have problem with Indonesia
at midday on friday the moon zine calls
the faithful to prayer it is not an
invitation but in order Archie is the
only province of Indonesia where Islamic
sharia law is in force it was introduced
in 2001 a questionable gift from the
central government when the sorry ah who
applied everything is team the authority
evaluate you every day you must go to
moes you must have the standard about
what you are really if you go to
somewhere with you friend or girl you'll
be arrested for attendees the reviews is
very personal right but the sorry a low
one the velocities become a public the
big brother we're what each other sorry
is a practicing Muslim but he rejects
the idea of being forced to pray if he
doesn't go to the mosque for prayers he
can't be out on the street so he stays
home he says the government introduced
Sharia as an instrument of control I
don't agree with the sorry hello because
it is politic he is not again is willing
it is the jakarta willing jakarta one
reduce the movement of independent in a
che like a referendum and when the goose
door role in Indonesia she give a che
sorry a low and you know we are a
Chinese don't reject something about the
Islam azhari deals with the violent past
notice a journalist but as a writer be
data
re going to be the category you can
write everything with you imagination
you said it for yourself but if you are
journalist you depend of your boss or
your newspaper but you know newspaper in
aceh in the CP world is very bad and all
of the journalist in Indonesia at the
time above of the military who I can
believe about the journalist it is three
thousand six hundred and fifty
kilometers from akshay to Bali and they
are worlds apart
many Westerners consider Bali a tropical
paradise in the early 20th century
European artists cultivated their
utopian fantasy that it was a perfect
place where humans and nature where it
won in perfect harmony Bali is known as
the Island of the Gods it has a thousand
Hindu temples the magic of the place is
an inspiration for the writer ochreous
meanie Daria car hi Jerry Akuma me now
varna trauma home biarkan Puget on come
en toda la momia wahi an at Leo I amumu
enter canto mentis on pimenta santana
jerkin para ssangyong monetary hair
Anangu a common muckin wang yun line
Derek dalaman a Korean co2 sukin de tu
mundo cola ha Akuma in contrast hace una
Rick tomentosa young Cooper Tintin
confer a Brittana aku Miguel my dr p mu
mu star boo me with klappa pan
oh Claire Ismene has lived on Bali for
25 years she was born in Jakarta to a
Hindu Brahmin family Valley buddy said
the Sun Valley is incredible look I've
worked here as a journalist since 1990
it's been a revelation a lot has changed
on the island I like to write about that
not scholarly texts of anthropology or
sociology but works of fiction novels
anthropology sociology at abhyudaya
fasting idea I won't read us to be
entirely immersed in Balinese society as
if they were part of it very buggy ended
in my celica Valley
the religious ceremonies and rituals of
the Hindu population are captivating
spectacle
but they embody a hierarchical caste
system with strict rules and tough
sanctions against anyone who breaks them
especially women
he from contre moi me and Erica person
if a woman from a higher caste marries a
man who is not from barley or belongs to
a lower caste she may no longer visit
her family she's discriminated against
yamla pagla who an nvidia there used to
be a ceremony called patty wangi to
expel a woman from her cast and her
family if she married beneath her but it
has been banned but Pescara Patera patty
wagon so that there's no patty wangi
anymore but discrimination still exists
as I described in my books women are
oppressed not by means of domestic
violence but through psychological
violence the Papac disregard Grobe's
her novel earthdance is about four
generations of women in one family and
the struggle for self-determination in a
complex and rigid caste system
one month one things have changed
nowadays Balinese women dare to get
divorced they're not afraid to break out
of the world of marriage they have the
self-confidence to live alone because
they're financially independent they
used to remain in bad marriages even
when they were treated badly but now
they take their fate into their own
hands and decide what to do with their
lives their bodies their thoughts their
children their social status they're not
afraid to make their own decisions sato
soy y asociados your affiliate a cotton
and pillion pili honey a la mina the
21st century has indeed reached valley
tourism is the most important industry
on the island and it has been a motor
for economic development and for social
change three million holidaymakers visit
Bali each year the impact of mass
tourism on the environment and on the
people of Bali is considerable paradise
is at risk I can't look up I'm not
living more and more land is being sold
to investors
there are even plans to build artificial
islands off the coast that would do more
than just disrupt the ecosystem
that we are barnacle young for the
Balinese the earth mountains and ocean
have very specific meanings and imagine
the sea becomes earth that's totally
incompatible with the hinder view of the
world it would be a great disrespect to
the people of Bali young I think I'll be
belly after added but tourism does have
positive aspects as well it helps the
young to establish contact with the
outside world they get to know people
from around the globe and make new
friends and learn
cited up from now oh when the up gun I
didn't set out to become a writer I come
from a troubled family my mother left me
when I was six I felt very lonely in
this world I wrote a lot in my diary
then on my birthday I would burn my
Diaries that was my birthday present to
myself during my childhood yeah I said
because i'm under for me writing was
therapy the girl was but when I was four
I had polio yeah before that I was a
healthy girl then suddenly I got ill and
couldn't go to ballet anymore I was just
a child but I felt my life was over
lucero sudah habis ketika moussaka na na
ito
took alder corridor okay is visiting her
friend choke Abby he is a fashion
designer who studied in London his
clothes are in great demand among the
upper class ladies of the Balinese
capital denpasar anymore huh gazonga
belly belly this is Balinese brocade the
dress was inspired by the sea goddess
can jangra to believing in java in bali
clothing is often closely linked to
religious rituals in it going delam
garage Chuck Abby has an ability to
reinterpret traditional garments such as
the caballo blouse dress combination
that's worn at ceremonies to make
something modern you can wear it to
parties oka is a fashion editor at the
local newspaper the Bali post her
enthusiastic reviews kick-started choked
Abby's career it's androgynous yes it's
masculine but the embroidery makes it
feminine and that's the idea yes it's
about black and white and two shades of
grey light and dark the colors represent
day and night dawn and dusk it's Holi
material that unites good and bad
sadness and joy choke Abby's jewelry is
also modeled on ritual objects layers of
the wave okay
to talk much I Yolo okay he says here on
Bali feminine beauty is celebrated in a
che under Sharia law it is often hidden
from view they are indeed worlds apart
oka likes to visit the market in
denpasar
she is not only a writer and journalist
but also a wife and mother and a great
cook
she and her family live in a quiet
neighborhood her son Pasha when I son
helps her make supper
okas husband is a poet translator and
art curator they met at a poetry
festival there's is not a conventional
pairing oka is a Hindu Brahmin her
husband a Muslim it's difficult to make
a living as a writer in Indonesia the
market is not large and few works are
translated into other languages sorry
that programming the song lady I've
never regretted being a writer it's
therapeutic for me and for my readers
online your mumbo jumbo goose I
from Bali it's now back to the capital
Jakarta on the island of Java
some of the biggest demonstrations
during the revolution of 1998 took place
at trisakti University they contributed
to the downfall of the dictatorship and
the emergence of democracy
today students living in a free society
our debt of gratitude to those of Linda
Chris Don T's generation who risked
their lives to fight tyranny
Linda Chris don t now writes for the
fashion and lifestyle magazine dare we
this is magazine for women in the middle
class and in high class for me it's
important to let them know about the
problem in the society and about how we
solve environmental issue problems
because women from this class they have
a lot of money and they have power maybe
they can contribute to change the
society
her activism and political work have
involved sacrifices I needs a lot of
freedom because I'm political person in
my writings if the Indonesian army or
whatever Army Special Force kidnapped me
if they kill me I will not be sad
because I don't have children I don't
have husband I don't have anything and
if I have a family maybe I worry a lot
about my life she may not have a family
of her own but she has close friends
comrades from their time in the
resistance in the 1990s back then nizar
patria was seized by the military when
the friends meet they often talk about
the past today they talk about the
father of another friend who was
abducted until his death the father
would make coffee every day for his
absence son he was already in a
wheelchair he was very sad that his
grandchildren didn't have a father he
just could not accept the fact that his
son was never going to come home again
today Indonesia is a democracy with a
fast-growing economy but it still has
plenty of social and political problems
so linda trest aunties work is far from
finished I have to keep going I have to
do what I think I have to do if you want
to change something in the society you
have to be brief to the debts maybe you
are not alone maybe in the world there
are some people like you maybe they'll
live in the world situations more than
me and because of that I never feel
alone
for Linda Chris don t it is hard to
shake off a sense of mistrust and
anxiety that might never change
but this too is part of her complex
identity she enjoys karaoke she sings
with friends from her student days their
shared past is an enduring bond
you
they sing in bahasa indonesia the
national language of this huge and
fractured country the language of
Indonesia's courageous writers who will
not be silenced
you
you